almost as a thought experiment can i ask
you to think about
if you're if some of your predictions
some of your analysis
some of your understanding of bitcoin is
wrong
in in the following sense where it will
not have the impact
uh that you have a
vision for it that you will not have the
scale of impact and perhaps in terms of
value will go to zero to something very
low and other cryptocurrency or other
financial systems will overtake it
what would be the reason for that in
your mind like
why might you be wrong if you look back
at it
yeah in the future what did you not
understand about bitcoin
that uh will result in that yeah
that's a great question i think for
that to happen one of two things would
have to obtain
one of two things that have happened for
bitcoin to just be
irrelevant basically um either
central banks totally clean up their act
and uh
you know stop engaging in rampant money
printing
which i don't expect that to happen
anytime soon i mean it looks like we're
normalizing this new regime of inflation
you know pro-inflation just to remediate
the the debt issues we have
uh so that would be one thing that would
make bitcoin
cryptocurrency much less relevant as if
everyone becomes totally assured of the
soundness
of sovereign currencies basically
namely the dollar like the dollar being
the main one uh
that it seems like we're going
completely opposite direction
but most people seem to be noticing the
stirrings of inflation in society
you might have noticed that too it's
showing up in commodity prices lumber
prices
and food obviously in financial assets
and
it'll show up in consumer prices
generally soon
uh but so that would be one way for
bitcoin to basically become irrelevant
because it's a you know it's a
dialectical thing bitcoin is
held in opposition to the established
monetary regime
so if they completely reform themselves
and
you know the dollar becomes super sound
once again
and the fed stops tinkering the way they
constantly do
then then we wouldn't need
cryptocurrency
as much the other thing would be if a
completely superior design for
a new sort of state independent monetary
system emerged
but it's really hard to even imagine how
that would come to emerge
you